une coupure d'oxygène en pleine pandémie
22 patients du coc vie 19 étaient sous
assistance grâce à ce centre
d'approvisionnement de l'hôpital mais à
cause d'une fuite accidentelle
l'alimentation en oxygène de leurs
respirateur s'est arrêté
les 22 patients sont décédés un drame
survenu dans un contexte de hausse des
infections aux qu'ovide 19 dans le pays
lié à l'émergence d'un nouveau variant
qualifié de double mutants les
bouteilles d'oxygène devienne un enjeu
crucial devant ce centre de recharge une
ambulance attend son stock de bonbonnes
d'oxygène les cylindres vides sont
remplis sur place avant d'être
distribués dans les hôpitaux où ils sont
plus qu'attendu tout autant que les
traitements plusieurs médicaments dont
le rêve des civils ne sont pas
disponibles mais c'est l'oxygène qui
fait le plus défaut et nous avons du mal
à prendre en charge les patients graves
qui ont besoin d'un respirateur
la plupart des patients sont donc
renvoyés chez eux car nous n'avons pas
assez d'oxygène et deresmes des civils
pour les soigner nous disposons d'une
usine de production d'oxygène qui a
environ 20 kg litres d'oxygène en temps
normal cela suffit pour six jours à une
semaine maintenant ils sont épuisés en
24 à 48 heures
nous devons renouveler le stock d'un
jour à l'autre et à l'avenir je ne sais
pas à quel point on devra le faire plus
fréquemment
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas eu de
problèmes mais la crise est bien là
désemparés certaines familles de malades
parviennent à s'approvisionner en
médicaments et en oxygène à des prix
exorbitants sur le marché noir
les habitants font aussi la queue pour
se faire dépister
la situation sanitaire dans le pays est
devenu plus que préoccupante
le pays a enregistré un nombre record de
2100 morts dus qu'aux vite 19 en 24
heures
l'inde rapportent également presque 315
mille nouveaux cas d'infection pour la
même journée la hausse des
contaminations a également explosé
depuis le début du mois
reconnaissant que l'inde livrent une
nouvelle fois une grande bataille le
premier ministre narendra modi a demandé
à ses concitoyens d'agir davantage
contre le coronavirus il a annoncé que
dès le 1er mai toutes les personnes de
plus de 18 ans pourront être vaccinés
avec un milliard trois cents millions
d'habitants l'inde est désormais le
deuxième pays le plus touché par le cos
vite 19 au monde après les états unis